oMG I can't believe you did ahh  if you tell be my friend Linda be my  friend Jeannie I'm talking to you those  housewife anyone have any hashtag cool  plans for hashtag Friday night having  hashtag fun hashtag today hashtag I  hashtag love hashtag hashtag this is  crazy she can't do that  the good guys win in the end I can't  believe the main character died it was  his father the whole time  LeBron has now passed MJ free Tom Brady  Steph shoes are wack oh man our  summertime special is lit right now  hashtag arenal and you should whip and  nae nae over here the burrito and  hashtag burrito and we are better than  burrito and delete your account  positivity is always positive go out and  conquer today never let go of your  dreams at Honda my a/c is working at  McDonald's I didn't get away my happy  meal every girl in summertime special is  not lit right now